hey guys I'm Ryan right he has a gun on
Veronica we're gonna watch the trailer
today for a film starring maybe one of
my favorite actors yeah consider more my
top ten non the top five William Smith
oh yeah where you might know him as Will
Smith some you might know him as The
Fresh Prince of bel-air do you know I do
the jazz clap yeah that's the Will Smith
I'm talking about it's called focus and
that's about as much as I know I thought
if I give a explanation as to how much I
like Will Smith that you guys would
think he knows a lot about this movie I
don't know anything about it one of the
AG the main actress is in wolf of wall
street martin Argo
Margo Debbie Robbie Robbie yeah you were
close and that's what counts
I see like you can't call us idiots we
were clearly not sure what the name we
didn't say like it's solidified as that
name so for me just see like mark and
then for her to be like Debbie it's like
yeah
we made it clear we don't really know no
it's just like obvious we're not trying
act like we know anything that doesn't
mean we don't know [ __ ] about anything
though exactly see cuz like we know [ __ ]
we know she had plenty of [ __ ] I know a
lot of [ __ ] I've seen [ __ ] done [ __ ]
yeah we really do love [ __ ] no boyfriend
would be accepting of these words right
now Veronica
oh it's rated R for language and sexual
content and brief violence this doesn't
sound like a typical Will Smith movie
his movies are normally not rated R he
usually keeps it pretty clean yeah he
usually keeps a pretty clean feistiness
yeah cool to see Will Smith's like
really sexual side really rough side
yeah yeah we should think about that and
brief violence is movies normally have a
lot of violence brief don't let this be
a letdown okay this is not wild wild
west which is one of my guilty pleasures
I'm personally like that movie a lot
they ain't bringing that
I think events anyone of anything
there's a science to getting people to
trust you I want in with your current
skills saying you don't maybe you could
teach me so bad does it feel sexy on
your face it does okay let's go
everybody gets a percentage make it
quick and get out here
congratulations you're a criminal you
might be one of the best I've ever seen
so we make so much money we all retire
two kinds of people in this world as
hammers and nails
you decide which one you want to be
that's good
why is it called focus I don't know I
guess you got to find out when you watch
the movie looks really sexy those two
leading I feel like the acting will be
good but something about the way I'm
sure it's just the trailer but something
about the way it's the tone that they're
kind of establishing for it looks a
little bit like it could be a lot better
some of it seems like a rehash of things
it's like we've also we've seen a lot of
these types of stories before I mean
sure this is a little bit more focused
like YES on the relationship between him
and this woman I hope they end up
together I guess they probably well
being
I want criminals to be happy I'm curious
to see what Mara Ravi lead in this yeah
it's so different from her wolf on Wall
Street performance like she has to be
like incredibly sexy and she's
incredibly sexy in this movie
no in this movie she's incredibly sexy
she is disgusting in wolf of wallstreet
just hard to look at hated hated baby I
hate it but in this one she looks sexy
she's doing a good job and it's nice to
see you vanilla and chocolate mix again
and wasn't how old is Will Smith I think
he's 67 years old he's looking pretty
good and he's yeah [ __ ] mmm right baby
you know my Robby's Australian is she
yeah she plays American pretty well yeah
she does I don't know this just look it
looks a little bit like what the [ __ ] is
the word for it I can't focus right now
see I did that see what I did
technically yeah it's a pretty big plot
but it's cool to see Will Smith in a
movie that definitely different than
anything else he's done before yeah or
at least what he's famous for like it
like this is like much more in the
realistic world you know at the same
time it's like clearly not an action
film it's like really it's my primary
to be about the performances so it does
still feel a little like a little bit of
an adventure and you know act a little
reaction I mean there's fighting scenes
I like Khan movies just in general
actually I always find them entertaining
I'm sure I'll find this entertaining I
mean the last half of the trailer really
focused on the [ __ ] like romance
stuff I don't know I just wasn't on
board for it it seemed so sappy and
cliche and then I just start looking
like a really one of those like
low-budget movies that like people who
make stuff up me whoa I'm only gonna
watch it because of how much I love Will
Smith but if this was in Will Smith I
probably wouldn't be too interested in
it I have so much respect for Will Smith
dude dude Will Smith is the [ __ ] if you
guys have not seen the video Will
Smith's words of wisdom on YouTube watch
it I've seen it a billion times
seriously if you apply a lot of that
[ __ ] you live a much happier life he's
very inspiring no he's the best man if
you look at his career and how much he's
like grown how long his career when he
started when he was like 18 or something
I think something you didn't have acting
classes either and now his son he's
fantastic he's great yeah he's totally
good loved him and after
you don't really like anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where we
keep it real that's the whole point of
the channel authenticity he gave me
about a two and a half hour lecture
wasn't a lecture it was a teaching
though it was fun let's just say we kept
it very authentic I don't quite get what
that means actually and Veronica has a
channel too there's a lot of blogging
covers there's gonna be some acting
stuff on there that's what I mainly had
known her for it was actually acting
she's really good not just saying that
cuz we're dating I mean I guess a part
of me is but the most part of me I've
always said that about you yeah always
I've never been like you can't act if
you want to see what he's talking about
you can check out my reels
see what we did there yeah we promoted
you teamwork teamwork power couple jiffy
is here can I possibly get a shout out
in the next video well jiffy is here
this is not the next video because that
was asked on September 27th like I said
a lot of requests so jiffy is here jiffy
you are here now with us stop jiffy
jiffy you know what's great that you
were able to not only create jelly but
open up a Carver how [ __ ] neat is
that
and now there's a peanut butter Oh
peanut butter you're right that's even
better
yeah peanut butter what it's way better
yeah no totally it just is all you're
being awful isn't being sarcastic when
we have a whole authentic talk if it
doesn't seem like you're being authentic
I really like peanut butter
no and jiffy created peanut butter
that's what makes them special
so jiffy you not only create a peanut
butter you've not only opened up a you
know lube masters shop a jiffy repair
shop and now you're a subscriber to the
greatest you too
Chen Oh everything then Sanderson please
can I have a shout-out please
well my Jewish friend he's Jewish his
last name Sanderson first name Ben come
on everyone knows you're Jewish if you
don't want people to know you're Jewish
right off hand you got to get your name
legally change Ben Sanderson are you the
brother of the Sanderson sisters who are
they
it is October who are they hocus-pocus
what's Henderson
what's hocus-pocus Sarah Jessica Parker
she's in it I love Sarah Jessica well
maybe you and Ben Sanderson should just
get a room since only you two know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
Lizzie Burton yes ah why is Jerry not
here for this one this woman loves Jerry
Jerry no she is saving herself for Jerry
no I can't skip I'm not good at that
stuff
hey Ryan and Jerry loving all the videos
they always cheer me up when I'm having
a bad slash boring day here in rainy
London Oh
keep up the good work and shadow will be
lovely please okay look I know you
really wanted Jerry to give you a
shout-out because you're always talking
about how beautiful he is
here's I'm gonna do for you I want you
to send me your phone number
I'm gonna pass it along to Jerry you
guys can Skype that's right saying you
up on a date
long-distance relationship it works out
Lizzie you can hit me up and we'll
figure something out yeah Lizzie Lizzie
just come out to LA and dude I'm telling
you Jerry will be yeah single London do
that accent will kill him he likes to
say Cheers
he does like to say tears kind of get
someone nerves sometimes
so those it'd be like that's a lot of
dick I could be like cooking beans or
something it'll be like that's a lot of
dishes new work for cool anyway Lizzie
get ready to be named mrs. Lizzie Cheers